I got something on my mind right here I
just put out a video how to start and
I'm reading all the comments and a
dawned on me I need to make the 2 minute
version of the raw version of what I'm
actually saying which is quite simple
I'm making this video for one reason so
that you can link to it when people [ __ ]
on you and doubt you I am tired of
people not starting and living their
life on one very simple thing which is
they're worried about what other people
think whether that's their mom their
friends and worst of all [ __ ]
comments in social media I mean this is
some sixth grade lunchroom [ __ ]
are you really really really not gonna
live your life based on somebody's
anonymous [ __ ] icon feedback that you
suck they [ __ ] suck there's three
[ __ ] trash that's why I [ __ ] found
a dumpster let them come to me let me
make this video so that you can point to
me so I can say to them very simply are
you serious my man are you serious like
you literally have time to leave
negative reviews on other people's [ __ ]
is your [ __ ] so [ __ ] up is it so sad
that you take your time to allocate
poison and negativity on other people's
stuff get out of the way and let people
do their thing now back to you guys who
are watching this it's enough you've
lived your whole life this way it
doesn't matter what they think when
you're [ __ ] 92 and you're sitting
there you're not gonna give a [ __ ] about
what punk man 96 had to say or even what
your aunt had to say who's miserable cuz
she never got hers so she's trying to
keep you down so very simply please take
the passion that is pouring out of my
[ __ ] face right now and run with it
and go do something if you need a little
burst here it is go do something because
the only thing that's holding you back
is you're worried about what other
people have to say you give up on that
[ __ ] and you're clean and you can go and
all of a sudden it's not how much money
you have or how much time you have you
just see that you can do it money ain't
I'm ain't [ __ ] of holding you back
compared to you're worried about other
people's opinions leave that [ __ ] in
high school it's time to go